What's better than a well-marbled ribby sizzling on the barbecue? A well-marbled ribby sizzling on the barbecue that was carefully selected by an Instacart shopper and delivered to your door. A well-marbled ribby you ordered without even leaving the kitty pool. Whatever groceries your summer calls for, Instacart has you covered. Download the Instacart app and enjoy $0 delivery fees on your first three orders. Service fees, exclusions, and terms apply. Instacart, groceries that over-deliver. Hello, everybody.
Hi there. So I am still in Chicago. I'm still doing my play. And I'm going to be here a little bit longer because we just found out that my play, Ashland Avenue, has been extended again to October 19th. So if you haven't had a chance to see it, please come see it. Oh, it's crazy. I've had the best time. It has been such a joy to watch you on this journey, lady.
Oh my gosh. I can't believe it. Every night I go out there and, you know, sometimes we have two shows a day. I just can't wait to do these scenes. I just love them. It's like I look forward to each scene for a different reason. There's like some moment that one of the other actors, I can't wait to watch them do it. Isn't that so fun to just get to watch and marvel at your co-stars like moment? Yes. Oh my gosh. The actor who plays my dad, Fran Geinen, I am constantly marveling at him. I just, You know, the other woman in the play with me, her name is Cordelia Dudney, and she is so good. And we only get one scene together. It's only like three pages. It's short, but it's so good. It's, oh, I look forward to it every night. I can't wait. As soon as she walks in the door, I'm like, yes, here we go.
Here we go. Yes. Also, you saw the show. You saw how funny Cheeky Johnson is. He plays my husband, Mike, in the play. Can you believe that before this play, he said he doesn't, he doesn't really do comedies. He does dramas, mostly dramas. I was like, what?
What? No, wait, he's so hilarious in the play. He is so funny. He gets the biggest laughs in the play. And we have this really funny scene together. I look forward to it every night. It's an act too. I love it so much.
I lived all of your scenes together. You guys have such fun chemistry, and I cannot believe he doesn't normally do comedies. He's so funny. And Angela, we didn't talk about this on our Friday chit-chat a while back, Will Allen, who's another actor in the play, he is an office trivia champion. We have to have him on the podcast lady. Yeah, you know, I met him when I came to see your play, and he told me he paid his rent
by winning office trivia quizzes. Yes, during the pandemic. That's right. And his team, they won the national online competition twice, and they're like the number one team in Chicago. Do you know what their name is? It's an office deep cut. What is it? I'm guessing. Is it? Is it an office reference? It is. What is it? Who's your worm guy? Oh, nice. It's a creed line. That's perfect. That's pretty great, right? Oh, that's so great. Well, lady, while you're doing your play, I'm gearing up for my cookbook tour. Oh my gosh, you're leaving so soon. It's happening. It's happening. We got the book. We got to hold it. It's beautiful. I'm so proud of it. And I can't wait to meet people and just, you know, get our cookbook out in the world. You're going out to sign cookbooks. Tell people where you're going. You're going
to three cities, right? We're going to three cities so far, and I'll put all this in our stories, but we are going to New Jersey. We're going to Dallas, and we are going to Santa Monica. And also, we're going to be in New York. We're going to be doing a little fun pop-up things in New York City, like the Today Show, the Sherry Show. I think we're doing some Man on the Street stuff. Man on the street. I have no idea. I know in New York. You and Josh running around? Yeah, I mean, it's going to be an adventure for sure. But the book is great and I can't wait for people to get it. You know what I just realized? This is the year that we both got to bring projects to the world with our husbands. Yeah. How cool is that? Really cool. And so special. It's really special. It's really special, right? Because it's like, here's the love of your life and now you've made something together and you're putting it out in the world. You have like this creative thing that you created together. It's so cool.
Yeah. You know, Lady, New Year's Rev premiered at the Toronto Film Festival. I know. And it's, oh, huge, amazing reception. Like, people love this movie. People love it. I can't wait until we can announce when this movie is coming out because people love it. I just saw a critic, like a little blurb, and I'm going to paraphrase this, but they had seen the movie and they said something like Green Day has made the next big teen or great teen movie. Something like that. I mean, it's amazing. I'm so proud to be in it. It's so cool. Oh, my gosh, listen to us. Okay. Okay. Sorry. Everybody, we're excited about the stuff we're doing. And that's great, right? It's good to be excited about the stuff you're doing in life, I think, especially if you're an artist. That's what we do. Yeah, absolutely. And, you know, we're also behind the scenes working on new episodes for Office Ladies that are so fun. And this week, we're going to run our appearance on another Odyssey podcast, The Golden Girls Deep Dive. It's hosted by Patrick Hines and Jennifer Samard.
two are so funny. Every week, they break down an episode of the Golden Girls. They do a really great job back in June. They had us on their podcast for an interview. We had the best time. They asked us to watch an episode of Golden Girls. We don't do like a full breakdown of it, but we do discuss it. Lady, it was so crazy to revisit that show. It makes me want to rewatch the whole show. I mean, it's so good. That's what surprised me, I think. And we kind of talk about this in our interview with them was like how good it was. So good. The nuance and the performances and the comedy. It was so, so good. You know, when we were prepping to do it, I read this article in Southern Living Magazine that has the 65 Best Golden Girls quotes and reading them, Jenna, it made me laugh out loud. Just reading
the quotes. Oh my gosh. Is it sort of like reading a bunch of Joe Bennett quotes? Yes, it is. Okay, here's one. I'll just read you one because there's 65. Dorothy, this is a quote from Dorothy, go to sleep, sweetheart, pray for brains. This is what I'm saying. That feels like something maybe Joe Bennett would say. I feel like Dorothy and Joe Bennett maybe have the same book of quotes. Yeah. Well, lady, I sent you a quiz because I thought we should find out which golden girl we are. Yes, you know, I can share both of these articles in our stories because they made me laugh and I think they're going to make you crack up too. But this quiz was great. And Jen, I'm really curious to hear who you got.
Who do you think I was? I think you might think I'm Dorothy. I think you are Dorothy. I was Rose. Oh, my gosh. You were Rose? I guess. I don't know. I answered all the questions and I got Rose. Who do you think I got? Rose. Yes. We're two roses. I think we are. I think we're two. people who just, like, have a lot of fun in life and, like, I don't know. Maybe we, all the ways we don't understand modern technology make us rose. I don't know. That's probably true. Although there were one or two questions that I felt like I was kind of teetering on that I feel
like could have made me a Dorothy. Same. Same. I think though, I'm not a blanche. I think we're Rose with the side of Dorothy. There it is. Oh, well, everyone, I hope you enjoy listening to this interview, you know, since we have both been so busy with some of our other projects, we leaned on some of our friends and other podcasts to interview us, and then we get to share it with you. So we really hope you enjoy it. Have a great week. At long last, I get to say the words, hello, Mother Cheesecake. Hello, Papa. Oh, we're so happy. You are so beautiful. You are glowing. You are radiant. You are the moment. You are the icon. I'm so happy to be back in the studio with you. I have missed you and
cheesecakes. I have noticed that we've started saying cheesies and I might like it even more than cheesecake. I love the cheeses. I love the cheesies. I'm seeing the cheesies on the road. They are always asking me about you. We send you videos. They love you. How are you? I'm great. I've missed you. I'm so glad to be back. I thought our graham cracker crust killed it. Steve is the greatest. I know. I know. He worked so hard. He was so excited to be here. He really wanted to like do you justice? Listen, we are a team and I love teamwork. My parents raised me. My mom was my softball coach. My dad, my brother's baseball coach. And more than anything, they stressed the power and importance of teamwork. So I'm so proud to be part of this team. I love you so much.
But we are getting to this episode, this interview with the office ladies, Angela and Jenna, from the office ladies, from the office. I'm obsessed. I cannot wait to talk to them. I can't wait either. Before we get there, I just want to ask you, what was it like to go viral like a hundred times? It was so incredible. And you know the best part is it's not something that was manipulated from our show. No. Where in the number hit me, I have this line, this is, that was root. That was pretty effing rude.
And, of course, I say the real word. Yeah. And it just took off. So it happened while I was sleeping, so to speak. And I woke up, and here's this viral moment. I mean, unreal. Like, I saw you, like, Madonna did it. Yeah.
I mean, that is crazy. It was everywhere. It was all over the internet. We're going to get way more into this in the future. but like the Tony's, you were nominated. It was glorious. How was it for you? It was incredible.
You know, to be nominated with Megan, my co-star was perfection. Yes. And then to be among those women, one of whom is Audra McDonald. And I've known her since she was Audra Ann McDonald. Is that right? Yeah, I met her singing at St. Clair's Hospital, which is no longer there, with Seth Rudetsky. And that day I met Norm Lewis. Oh, my God.
And Audra. And her name at that time was Audra Ann. and she was in between her first audition for Carousel and her callback. No way. Which ended up being her first Tony Award and changed everything for her. Yeah, yeah. You know, and we're the same age, you know, so it's just, it was so special. We're like, we're still here, you know?
And we just kind of sent each other supportive messages, and that was really great. That's what I love, because it, tell me if I'm wrong, but it seems like it doesn't feel competitive between the nominees, that you are all really supporting each other. It's inherently competitive because that's technically what it is. But if you don't treat it, it that way and just have fun, then it really is the right way to do it. And that's, I believe, the way we try to approach it all. Well, Cheezies, listen, if you will allow it, we're going to do a
whole talk about your last couple of months because you've been away. You've been so busy. Like, everything has gotten crazy for you. Yeah. But right now, we need to get to this interview with Angela and Jenna from the office, from the Office Ladies podcast. I got to tell you, we work with a company called Odyssey. They are the ones who sell our ads for us. They support us. They've been marketing us. They have been so, so supportive of this podcast. And from the beginning, we were like, it'd be such a dream. Because Angela and Jenna worked with them as well. And we were like, it'd be such a dream to get them.
We're like, we're going to really try to make this happen. And as far back as Christmas, both Angela and Jenna wanted to do this interview. They just are so busy and had so much going on. It finally made sense for them to do it now. We're going to have a bunch of social media. So go to our social media so you can see some of the videos of this conversation that we're about to have. I'm so delighted. I can't wait to talk with you with them.
Yeah, me too. And, you know, one of the things we're going to talk about is the Barbara Thorndyke episode of the Golden Girls for a million reasons. But, like, technically, I have so many questions for them about being a guest star, what it takes to be a good guest star, working with guest stars. They're the experts. I've got a lot of questions about this, just about, you know, their podcast, superstars, how did that happen? It's going to be a great conversation. So, uh, shall we dive in? Let's dive in.
So Jenna Fisher and. Angela Kinsey, I cannot tell you what an honor this is. To be on a Zoom, not just with the two of you, but with Jennifer Smart as well. Like, I don't know what I did in this life to get to be on the Zoom with the three of you. We are overwhelmed. We're honored. Our listeners have been begging for this crossover forever. So welcome to the Golden Girls Deep Dive podcast.
Welcome. Thank you so much for having us. Yeah, we're so tickled. I have to say, I love that it's a glasses convention. We're all wearing my glasses. Oh, yeah. Cheesecakes. Yes, we love it, don't we?
We're all looks so cute. It is. And I want to be. And I want to be able to see you. Yeah, that part. That part right there. You two are such big stars. I was waiting for like the presidential.
Like, please hold for Angela Kinsey and Jenna Fisher. And then like you pop in very officially. But you're so down to earth. You're just like the rest of us. Oh my gosh. Yeah. Angela and I are, we're besties. And we do the podcast together.
And we do all the other things together too, like organize each other's closets. And we don't have assistance or anything. It's just us, just us, gals. Just us gals. Jen refuses to organize my closet. I've been begging and begging and begging. Oh, it's so fun to do it together. But I don't have months.
I don't have months is the problem. That's how long it would take. Oh, sorry, Patrick. I know. So sorry. Listen, here's the thing. We all know as huge fans, you are both sitcom icons. I mean, icons.
The office is an iconic sitcom. It's lasted the test of time, as has the goal. Golden Girls. It's also an iconic sitcom. What is your relationship to the Golden Girls? And what do you think it is about shows like yours and the Golden Girls that make them so timeless, if you had to guess? Oh, well, gosh, you know, to be able to be a part of a show that people keep connecting to over the years, over and over multiple generations. You can't even believe that you won that lottery ticket, you know? And we all grew up with shows like that. We all grew up with shows that we watched with our parents when we didn't even and hang out with them otherwise, right, in those teen years. And so that's really meaningful. And I think the Golden Girls and the office and shows like them that stand the test of time have relationships that people connect with, right? And Jen and I, we've sort of seen this as we go out in the world. Like, whether you're at a hospital or you're at a homeroom classroom, there's always a Dwight, right? And it doesn't matter where you work. There's probably a persnickety, Angela.
Yeah. And then you've got to have that relationship you're rooting for. And I think for the Golden Girls, it's that sisterhood, right? And for the office, it was Jim and Pam. I like to think some people were rooting for Dwight and Angela. I 100% was. I was like, somebody's got to set him right. She's the only one who can do it.
That's right. That's right. Her and her clipboard. I married and Angela, by the way. So I totally 100%. I married like the child of Angela and Pam. Steve is the marriage of those two characters. So I very much relate to that dynamic.
Well, I just think those shows have such huge themes about life and love and loss and trying to find your way. And whether they're set in a sort of community in Florida or in a small office, that's what people connect to. You know, it's not that we work at a paper company. That's not it. It's that journey of life that happens. Yeah, I agree with all of that. So I watched the Golden Girls when it was on. Oh, okay, good.
Everybody else, appointment viewing. Yes. Appointment television, yeah. Yeah, one of my favorite shows. And I hadn't watched it in forever until we said we were going to do this collaboration. But then something that I remembered in watching it was like how Golden Girls wasn't afraid to get dramatic. Like all these storylines started flooding in for me.
And I was like, I think that might be part of it, too, is that, you know, it rings all the comedy bells. But then every once in a while, it kind of like, ooh, it tugs at your heartstrings. Mm-hmm. Or makes you think about something. Like, oh, yeah. Yeah. Do you think in that vein that the office comes from that sort of lineage? Because the office certainly has.
I was thinking, too, about, like, there are moments when you see Angela cry. And those are some of the most emotional moments of the office for me. Like, Pam is such a sweet soul. But, you know, and my God, the Pam's arc towards the end. Like, it's very tear jerky. But I do think it surprises people when they go back and look at the Golden Girls that there are moments you could cry. There are moments that are really dry.
And, you know, do you think that the office comes from that sort of tradition in sitcom? Yeah, I think a little bit. I mean, I know that that was kind of one of the gifts. of the way we shot the show was that we could pull the camera back and we could observe these more private, intimate moments of characters, which is something you don't get to do a lot in comedy. And so, yeah, I mean, 100%. Yeah, and I think Golden Girls is just classic television comedy writing.
You know, you have each character is their own little season and spice, and they bring something unique. They have a unique point of view. And you can count on that point of view. and you get excited for it. You know Sophia, right? You know what she's going to deliver. Yeah. And I think the office had that too. Your characters, they grow a little bit, but they don't grow so much that they're still not who you want them to be. And that's just great, great comedy writing. Also great performing, great acting, because you are such beautiful actors in your show. And so, too,
are the actors in the Golden Girls. And give me any actor who's capable of, comedy, and I guarantee you they can be a sad clown when they need to be. But it's not always true in reverse. So my hat's off to both of you. Thank you. Just very, very talented. You're welcome. We have a Golden Girls Office crossover. We do. Yes. What is it? And I was so tickled when we heard it in this episode. Tell me. What are you talking about? I'm talking about Kent Zabornack. Me too. Because the inscription in the book that Barbara gives Dorothy, It says to Dorothy Zabornack, and I said, oh my gosh, I just heard his name in the episode. That's right.
Yes. That's right. Our co-exec producer, Kent Zabornak, was an assistant to Susan Harris, and she liked his last name so much that when she had to name Dorothy, she gave Dorothy the last name Sabornaq. And then that's the origin story. Yes. But I didn't realize that he also worked on the office. That's incredible. He was a producer for those first seasons that really.
developed the whole show and yeah he's wonderful and and that is just it just tickled us when we found that out and he did end up he also worked on golden girls and he told us because we asked him we were like zabornak that's a very specific name and he said that when he did eventually meet b arthur and she found out that her character was you know his namesake he said she was so kind and she almost became like a second mother to him. He just loved her. Oh my God. So sweet. That is incredible. I wanted to ask the two of you as actors, the thing about the Golden Girls, it's never been off the air, right? Like, from the day it was on for four decades now, it's never been off the air. It's one of those comfort shows. And when we were asking our listeners what they wanted to know about from you all, one of the questions that you got
in a bunch of different ways is sort of what does it like for you as actors to know? Like, I mean, in my house, we've watched the office straight through no fewer than eight, nine times. And I mean, that is a commitment, but now you can get through it in three months or whatever, you know? And what does it feel like for you all to know that like this is going to outlive you? No question. Like it'll be around long after we leave this plane. You know, and not very, very, very few shows, I think have that kind of history eventually. How does it feel to be a part of that? I mean, it's very humbling. And, Also, it's very moving to me. I mean, I know that we, our show, the office, it does everything from just beyond the background while people make dinner to helping people while they're going through a medical crisis. You know, I can't tell you how many people tell us, oh, this is what we watch to get through chemotherapy or this helped me when I was grieving, the loss of someone. And so to be that kind of comfort and
constant. It takes something that was just the most fun thing in the world to do, a comedy television show, into feeling so meaningful and I'm so happy, you know? Yeah. Yeah. I mean, I think we just sit in a lot of gratitude. And it was so much fun to do. And, you know, I had this writing professor that said, what's a pleasure to write is a pleasure to read. And I always thought about that when we were on the set because we were having so much fun. And I just was like, surely, I hope people watch this and have that same joy that we have doing it. We spent most our days trying not to ruin each other's scenes because we were laughing so hard. And that was just what a gift. And to know that it has such meaning that will just go on and on is very surreal. It's special.
It's humbling, like Jenna said. And then it's also, it's also kind of strange. sometimes because I forget, you know, you just go about your life, you're at the grocery store or whatever, you're dropping your kid off at soccer practice. And that part of your life is on the back burner in your mind and someone will see you and yell, you know, like, green is horrish. And you're like, what? What? And then you're like, oh, yes, right, of course. That's right. With Amex Platinum, access to exclusive Amex pre-sale tickets, score you a spot trackside. So being a fan for life turns into the trip of a lifetime. That's the powerful backing of Amex. Pre-sale tickets for future events subject to availability and
vary by race. Terms and conditions apply. Learn more at Amex.com slash Y-Amex. Hit pause on whatever you're listening to and hit play on your next adventure. This fall get double points on every qualified stay. Life's the trip. Make the most of it at Best Western. Visit bestwestern.com for complete terms and conditions. are legitimate podcast stars now. I'm going to combine this a little bit, but like, what does that feel like? You said earlier, there's been a learning curve, which is so humble of you to even say. But of course, there is anything in life. But, you know, what inspired you to make the podcast in the first place? And was it important to you that it wasn't just a recap podcast? So,
you know, all of those as the legitimate podcast stars you are. Well, I think one of the biggest things was ever since the office ended, Angela and I wanted to work together again. Nice. There is nothing like getting to go to work every day with your very best friend, the person you trust the most. Yeah. And so we were always looking for that opportunity. And we didn't know what that was. We were like, is it a TV show? We would joke that we wanted to take over the fourth hour of the today show and just drink
wine and chat in the mornings with people about events. We were like, we just need to be best friends working together. But then the other thing that was happening after the office was we were like full-time, now we were in the season of our lives with our young children. And going off to a set for like 12, 14 hours a day was really hard on our mom hearts. And we would talk about that too. We would say, how can we have a really fun creative job that we do together that also allows us to be at all of those milestones as a parent, at all of the soccer games and the volleyball games and the school performances and the parent teacher conferences? Like, is there, what's that job? Can we find
it. And that was how we kind of honed in on podcasting. Yeah. Now, was this your idea? And if you don't mind me saying, we were chatting a little bit about this before we started. I got into podcasting about nine years ago because I fell in love with the art of podcasting. And then, of course, the zone got flooded. And it's not very often that a game changer podcast presents itself. And your podcast came out and was so instantly beloved and seemed to be exactly what the world needed. at the exact moment. So I guess my question is, like, was it your two's idea to do the podcast?
Did people approach you about the podcast? And did you know that you wanted to, like, really give the behind-the-scenes experience more than just recapping the episodes? I mean, the way it started, we had no idea that it was going to be a rewatch podcast. Really, we had a ton of memorabilia, photos, scripts, you name it.
Jenna and I sort of were the historians of the show. We saved everything. We took a ton of pictures. And we started this project that we had wanted to do for years to clean out our sheds and closets. I told you we cleaned things together. This really happened. And the thing is, neither of us were doing it until we're like, okay, we're both going to do it. And in that process, I think I found out that I clearly have some weird obsession with baskets. I had like 32 baskets. Jenna had so many lamps. I'm like, why are you keeping all these lamps? I was convinced I was going to rewind. them. I know. I know. But anyway, we found boxes and boxes of our office memorabilia. And we were like, we want to preserve this for our kids. We weren't really sure how. And we decided to each take a Halloween, our bin of Halloween pictures and stories and rewatch a Halloween episode and sort of just like make notes, right? Like an oral history sort of like we just wanted to get it down. Like what would you call that? Like journaling out loud. journaling out loud. And we weren't, you know, no real idea what we were going to do with that session. We just wanted to do something with it. We didn't know if it would eventually lead to a book or a podcast or just us getting this history down for our kids. So Jenna came over and I got lunch. And we sat in, we have a garage that we kind of made into a bonus room. And we sat on my IKEA couch out there and put my iPhone between the two of us on the couch and hit record.
Yes. And Jenna shared hers, which was a very structured, outlined, thoughtful. I like wrote like a three-page document. Yes. And I, you see these note cards behind me? I had a stack of these note cards with my notes and ideas and pictures. And the two of us had such a different approach to a shared memory. We both had the same memory. And we came at it from such two different perspectives. And we just laughed and talked. And it was really fun. And I hit Stop Rec, court at the end. And my husband is a really good editor. And he listened to it. I sent it to Jenna and her husband and my husband. And our husbands listened to it. And Josh said to me, Ange, this is a podcast. And Jenna's husband said the same thing. He was like, you guys have something here. Wow. Wow. So we took it out. Yeah. Josh edited it to a little sizzle, you know, kind of thing. And we took it out ourselves. Wow. That's incredible. I love that story. And it just goes to show you everyone, like, just create. Just do the thing. You never know what can become of it. I'm inspired, Patrick. I do want to ask the first listener question because they brought up memorabilia. Oh, yeah. You know what I mean? Yeah. We got a question from a listener named Kathleen. So for both of you, for followers of office ladies and office BFFs, we all know what props set decor they kept from the office. I want to know, Kathleen wants to know, what Golden Girls prop or decor they would.
love to have. Oh, well, I mean, okay. Jen is raising her. No, you go first. I have something from this episode that I want very badly. What? Okay, yes. So we're going to talk about the episode Dorothy's new friend in a minute. So that's the episode you're talking about. Okay. But I would take, just in general, I would take anything in their kitchen. Oh, yes. The tablecloth, like any of the kitchen decor is amazing. from this episode specifically, though, I've become somewhat obsessed with Blanche's yellow pants suit.
And if I could buy it and wear it, I would 100% do it. All right. I feel like you could rock so many of Blanche's out. Like the red number with the thing at the top, oh my God, you'd be perfect in that. It's, they all look comfy.
They do. They look like they breathe and move with you. Yeah. You know? Yeah. I'm obsessed with all of the wicker and the coral. So like that furniture set in the living room, the couch and the chair,
I mean, I want it. I want that wicker chair. Yeah. I truly do. And there's 72 coral napkins. They have so many coral napkins. You know what I would take? If I can take anything. And I would frame, we have big walls in my apartment and I would take the front door with that exclamation mark. You know, I don't know if you've seen it, but there's like the there's an exclamation mark sort of chiseled into the front door. And I would put it on the wall behind like plexiglass or something. Oh, yeah. Oh, I love that.
Or you could make a dining table out of it. Oh, that's a good idea. I would take the copper lobster mold on the wall that looks like a penis. Yes. Well, let's talk about, so, you know, we asked you, and you so kindly did watch the episode, Dorothy's new friend, which is, you know, it's made iconic by the actress Bonnie Bartlett. It's the episode where Barbara Thorndyke is Dorothy's new friend and she's kind of a jerk and, you know, the other women see it, but Dorothy doesn't really see it.
So my question is, do you think this episode is iconic and if so, why? I mean, I do because it's about friendship and it's that new person that enters in sort of the old guard, the group, you know, and that is a very common theme. It's super relatable. We've all lived it. We have. We've all had a good friend group and then had a new person join, and you're like, well, what, what's, what's happening here? Right.
So, and then also, it has that very sweet ending where, you know, Dorothy is going to stand up for her friends and, and her mom and her mom's friend, you know. So I loved the ending. I always, whenever I hear the word metaphor, it always takes me right back to this, you know, I know what a is dear and then also like the titles of the books like there was a the episode that we're actually doing our regular episode on today when we're done with this there's a shot of the hospital from the outside of this is like Biscayne Bay hospital and I'm always saying like so dark the waves on Biscayne Bay but Jenna what do you think? I'm sorry Patrick yeah what I'm sorry to the group sorry what is a metaphor don't don't worry about it I'm not worried about it okay I also just loved and I know we're jumping around here but I loved how snooty Barbara was and her brooch, you know, that she found in Morocco, and now she's never had writers walk again. I'm like, and then I love the snark. Was it, was it Rose who said our blanche that you can't wear it with plaid? I just loved that. And then I love when someone is snooty and purposely gets a name wrong. Like the fact that she kept calling her match was so
snarky and passive aggressive. And intentional, right? Like she's, the character's, literally doing it up. It's such a nasty move. There was a girl when I went to college that when she didn't like someone, she would purposely get their name wrong. And it was a whole thing we all picked up on. So like, if your name was Betsy, she'd be like, hi, Bet. I'm like, bet.
Since when you called me, Bet? Or she'd be like, seriously, you'd be like Amy. And she'd be like, hi, Emil. And you're like, a meal. Like, what? She would just get like a few letters off. And I'm like, oh, she is so damn snarky. Ew.
Yeah. My other question, like, in my opinion. opinion, one of the things that makes that show work so well is the guest star. And so I wanted to talk to you about your experiences working with guest stars, you know, whether like memorable experiences on the office that worked great or ones that didn't. And if you all were ever guest stars, like what your experience was. Yeah. I mean, the person who comes to mind is Amy Adams, who came in very early on in our first season as a guest star and just crushed it with the, like type of acting that you had to do and the looking at camera or not looking at camera. And, you know, Amy Adams wasn't marquee Amy Adams when she did our show. Yeah.
After she filmed... She wasn't even nominated for her first Academy Award yet. No, no, I hadn't even come out yet. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So that was crazy. And then what was so freaking cool about her was that she did her first episode.
And then in the second season, when she was now Academy Award nominee Amy Adams and like being like courted for all the biggest movies, she was like, yeah, I'll come back and I'll do like four lines in an episode and then I'll go sit on a boat for three days in the middle of the night and don't boost crews with the eyes. Like she was just like so cool and up for it even as her star was like skyrocketing, you know?
That's cool. She said in an interview somewhere, she's like, you couldn't have kept me away. She's like, I would have taken time off from whatever I was doing to go back. That was clear. That was clear. And, you know, for the threat level midnight episode, they reached out to her because they really, you know, the idea was that he had been filming threat level midnight for years. And there would be, like, scenes with, like, people who you'd seen years ago on the office.
And they really wanted her in, like, a flashback scene. And she wanted to do it so bad. and I can't remember the reason why Ange, right? But, like, she was on a movie. She was, like, in another city. She was like, I'll take a red eye. I'll do it. And, like, the movie wouldn't let her out.
Like, she was like, I want to do this so badly. Yeah. Now, Jenna, you just called Angela Ange. Does that mean you don't like her? No, are we good? That's a nickname. Nicknames are allowed. Okay, that's allowed.
Okay. Full-on, not your name, snark. Yes. A little smart. Yeah. I hope people called her by the wrong name, just to tie it in a bow. Yes. No, Angela, do you have a guest star that you remember working with that stands out as a memorable experience good or bad?
I mean. And if it's bad, you don't have to say their name. Oh, no, no. I mean, just memorable. Like, when I think of someone who walked on the set and it was like electricity went through the room, it's Idris Elba. I mean, when he walked on the stage. Electricity just went through the room at the mere mention of the name. Everybody was just like, oh, hi.
Like it was, he was so charming and he totally got his character. He knew exactly who Charles was. He was like amazing and went toe to toe with everyone and then was also incredibly charming. So, yeah, that is one. And he really did. It translates into the episode because it's like that was his character. Like everyone was just like swooning all around him like in the episode. Yeah.
I would feel like walking on to our stage at that point because, you know, you. You know, when we talked about Amy Adams, that was early in the show. But now this is later in the show. It's very established. The characters are established. And to walk in as a guest star then, I feel like would have been really intimidating. I would have been intimidated. And he was just, he was there, man.
He was ready to go. You know, something about the office that was very unique to our show was that we all had to be there all day every day because we were in the background of each other's scenes. The bullpen was open. So if you were a guest star, you had to be ready for that. You had, like, that comes with the job. And I cannot tell you how many humongous stars, Kathy Bates, Idris Elba. Timothy Alphant.
Yes. You know, Will Farrell, you know, came through our doors and just what incredible artists they were because they were like, yeah, I'll sit here for four hours. while you guys figure out a scene in front of my desk. We were so lucky with our guest stars. You know, someone who popped in my head who just absolutely delighted me was Andy Daly as Ben Franklin. Oh, he's so good.
He's been Franklin. I couldn't get through those scenes with him. Like, so funny. Yes. You know, it's just popping into my mind, and I'm sure she doesn't count as a guest star, but there is another Golden Girls' The Office crossover, and I wonder if you know this. Malora Hardin. I was going to guess, Melora.
I mean, you know, we just like... Malora was on Golden Girls? No, her dad was. Her dad played... I know. I think his name is Jerry Hardin, and he played the professor that sexually harassed Blanche.
Do you remember that episode? Yes, that was Malora's dad? Yeah. And that's Malora's dad. And I, when we were doing a deep dive on it, and I waited till the end, I'm like, Jen, you're going to die when I tell you who, like, who he's related to. I think his name is Jerry Hardin.
And it's funny if you look at him, he looks just like her. Like, you can see, like, you can, like, see her face on him. I do remember that you found him attractive. Listen, I didn't want to be controversial and be like, oh, the guy who sexually harassed Blanche is hot, but, like, Malara Hardin's dad's kind of hot. I mean, Malara is gorgeous. She's beautiful. And the only reason why she came to mind is because of everyone on the show, I feel like Malora had the biggest acting pedigree as far as generational, you know? Like, she grew up acting.
I knew her family. Her dad was in the business. Her mom was a manager and a teacher and an acting coach. Malara was on Little House on the Prairie. Yeah. She was. Yes. Yes.
It's so funny because I am not an actor. I don't really understand the hierarchy of what a set is like. But I understand that you all are like the stars. And then, you know, Malora Hardin comes in and she's a guest star or whatever. But her, Jan felt like everybody's boss. And it really felt like you all were afraid of her. Like it translated into so far as like, we know they're acting. We know this isn't real.
But I can't imagine they actually like her because she's so mean. You know, like she was so perfect. And it was also lived in it. And I was thinking about what you were saying about the guest stars being like Kathy Bates, being like, sure, I'll come in and figure, watch you guys. I bet that was so fun for them. Like the office. And this is kind of a question.
Like, were you able to realize how iconic it was while you were doing it? Because I would think even when you're a Kathy Bates or a James Bader or an interest Selba, they get to come and play in that world for a week or however long it is. And maybe did you recognize that even though they were big stars, that you were big stars and that like them getting to watch you work was probably really fun for them. It's so funny. We interviewed Kathy Bates for office ladies. And she talked about how intimidated she was.
And we were like, wait, what? I know. I know. It's wild. Yeah. I just love that you shared how game these. actors were to sit there on set and not, you know, have someone stand in for them or just wait in their trailer or their room. It's just such a reminder and a lesson to be just a team
player and to have fun and not not take it so seriously and just to have fun, you know, and be a good, be a nice person, be someone people want to work with. It's really lovely to hear that. Well, to be fair, we were a fun place to work. Like, you didn't want to be in your trailer, you know, you were going to miss out on something because we were, if we weren't doing a hilarious scene, we were doing bits off camera and having the best time. So you did not want to be in your trailer. There are some sets where you're like,
I'm going to need to go to my trailer. Yeah, yeah, yeah, sure. Toxicity happening that I want to get away from. Yeah. But all of these big stars, we were a really artistically satisfying place to be, I think. I love that. I want to get to more listener questions,
but I would be remiss if I didn't tell you, Jenna, that like, Pam, you're missing things is the thing that my husband and I scream at each other whenever one of us is not in the room that they need to be. And do you remember that episode? It was like the episode at the lake. No.
Oh, my God. It is so iconic in our house. Refresh my memory. Is Michael? Was Michael the one that said it? Yeah, it's Michael from off camera because it was like the vacation day where you all go to the lake
and you, but like you didn't get to have a vacation because you had to like walk around and write down what everybody was doing. Yes, I had to tear knowledge and notes. Yes. And so there's a shot right before it goes into the commercial where you're like talking to the camera and you're just kind of like I just wanted to like come to the beat. And from off camera you hear Michael go, Pam, you're missing things.
And it is, I have watched it so many times. And my husband and I just like scream it down the hallway to each other. And then Angela, of course, save Bandit. Like, do people just shout that at you in parking lots? Yes. People yell Save Bandit. And then, you know, for me, because I get saved Bandit a lot, I know Jenna gets, please don't throw garbage at my head. Is that what you get, Jenna? Please don't throw garbage at me. Please don't throw garbage at me. And then I have gotten green as hoarse, but the one that like I always remember because I was like, what?
I had gone to see you two and I was walking to my seats. I was going down a staircase and you know the section right above you, like the balcony. As I'm going down, these young guys come to the edge of the balcony and they yell across. the section, Angela, I would take the Da Vinci Code so I could burn the Da Vinci Code. And that's like such a random thing. And I was like, oh my gosh, right. That's when we all say what we would take in the deserted island. I mean, it's also the other one that we say to each other all the time is a glass of warm milk, two chapters of a good book, and lights out by nine. That's how I sleep at night. That's such a good one. Yeah. All right. Do you,
You have time for a couple more listener questions? Sure. We have tons of time. Yeah, we're here. Oh, my God. I love you guys. Okay, so we're officially making a podcast together. So Jessica says, I would love to know where they would live if they could move and live like the Golden Girls.
I think it'd be funny to see an episode with Angela, Pam, Kelly, and Phyllis in a house for a weekend. Oh, my gosh. That's the spin-off we need. That is the spin-off. That would be so good. Where would the house be? and what do you think that, like, what would the situation be? I don't know, but Meredith definitely lives next door.
Yeah. We won't let her live with us, but she's, like, moved adjacent to us. Maybe she's in the garage apartment. Yes. Yes. I love it. Here's a question I love. If you two could have guest starred on an episode of the Golden Girls, which one would it have been?
Oh, I don't know them well enough. I wish I did. Or if you could be a character, like, if you could even, That's what we always ask. Yeah. Who would you be? Yeah, which golden girl would you say you are and which one would your friends say you are? Oh, that's a good one.
Well, I know who you would say I am. Dorothy? Yes. Yes. Dorothy is a Bornaq. Yes. Am I rose, Jenna? Yes.
You are. I am Rose. You are. Although I know a Malamar is a cookie. Right. Yeah, that's so funny. You know, if I could go on the Golden Girls and be in one episode, I would want to be there the day that Bert Reynolds shows up to the front door.
Oh, my God. And so, me, it's just like, hey, Mark, we're off to lunch or whatever. And everyone else is like, what? I mean, talk about, like, a great door opener guest. It's so good. And the line is, he leans into Sophia, which wants the slug? And they all raise their hands. It's so good.
All right, this is a good one. If they could have a mashup between the two shows, which two characters would you love to have a scene together? My two requests would be Meredith and Blanche and then Dwight and Sophia. Oh, yeah. I mean, I also think Michael with any of them, really and truly, have a sit down with Michael with any one of those ladies, and that would be off to the races.
Like, Michael and Rose would be some really good content, I think. I could also see Michael on a date with Blanche because she would blow his mind. And he did date Pam's mom. Exactly. Right. Yeah, yeah. Oh, true. Wait, here's a last question from Heidi.
It says, if Pam and Angela were to show up on the Golden Girls, what would they look like? Are they related to someone? Are they neighbors charity event? Like Mrs. Claxton. Are they neighbors charity event? Maybe they're on a business trip to the Sabre headquarters. Oh, I think in my heart of hearts, we'd be neighbors, and we would be those ladies that do the same walk every morning, you know? Like, I have these two ladies that live at the end of my street.
They're side by side. They're widowers. They do this walk. And one day, I had lived in my house 10 years. And one day they walked by and they said, oh, it's so nice you finally got your fence done. I was like, how long has this bothered them? How many times? That's, in my heart of hearts, Jenna and I would be these two gals that walk by and say, like, comment on people's yards.
I love it. Oh, my God. I love it. I have a question after watching this episode. Please. Which, yes, which is so a big theme in this episode is like first impressions. Like, you know, Barbara makes this really great first impression, but then it's not lasting. But then she has, you know, she talks about how like, well, maybe I just got a bad impression.
first impression of your friends. I'll give them another try. Do you guys remember your first impression of one another? That is so a, it's so kind of you to ask us a question. I, if I may, Miss Simard. So Jennifer Samard is a huge Broadway star. She's a three-time Tony nominee. She's co-starring and Death Becomes her on Broadway right now. She's got her third time nomination. If you go to her, did you, are you guys? Are you guys on TikTok? Do you like follow the trends? We're not on the tickety talk, but we're, we're, we might get on it. I don't I don't know. Jennifer, can I, I have to like pause right now. Yes. I saw death becomes her with my mom and I did not connect those dots. Holy shit. You're amazing. Oh, thank you, Jenna. Oh, my God. Yeah. Thank you. It is a triumph and you are so freaking funny. Thank you. And I saw you on the Tony's in your seat with your little sign. Yes. My little sign. Yes. That's the ticket. Talk Patrick's referring to because that
That's from the show That was rude And that went viral And there's this There's this video of Bette Midler Who's a friend of Jens Coming backstage after the show And Bet Midler on her knees
Bowing to Jennifer Like saying like how Wait is that online Yeah It's on my Instagram No I don't know how Because you know you get like the algorithms I saw that
And I was like damn I mean Wait a second Are you going to on stage tonight? Yes. Yes, I am. Oh my gosh, Jen. Yes. Well, thank you for hopping on and talking with us. She's been doing this the whole time. Let me tell you. Like, Jen, we've been making, we're, we've been making this podcast as long as she's been doing Death Becomes Her. Like, she is, she is such a rock star. Why would I give up the opportunity to meet incredible humans such as yourself?
Oh my gosh. Jen, I'm so, I'll sleep when I'm dead. I'm so humbled because, I mean, Jen, Jen, Jen, and I both just, we know what it takes to do a podcast and show up and that energy and to know that you're also then going to go out on stage tonight. Thank you so much for taking the time out from your preparation. I know. My mind is blown right now. Thank you very much. I don't know how I didn't put that together before. No, because you know why we're all, just we're, I think every actress is inherently a character actress. You have to disappear into that part, you know. So I, I know that's, you wouldn't know me if you saw me on the street half the time. So I take it as a compliment to be perfectly honest.
Well, I saw the show with my mom and my mom and I were just like, I can't believe we got to see those two ladies on stage. We feel so privileged. That's the cool thing about theater, you know. You either see it or you don't. And it's a moment in time, although I have a feeling this is going to be a real long moment because, I mean, you know. It's very good. It's very good. But, wow.
Wow. That was it. I mean, I was a fan of Jen's from years and years and years ago. And then over the pandemic, I found out that Jen was listening to my other, I make a true crime podcast as well. And Jen was like a listener to that podcast. And so I was blown away by that. And so I reached, I like slid into her DMs. I'm like, hi, I love you. Like, thank you for listening. And we went back and forth. And then she started coming over. I think I slid into your DMs because, you know, True Crime Obsessed is a hugely successful podcast. And a girlfriend in mine wanted to do one of our own during the pandemic and you were so kind to information share. But my first impression of Patrick was one of incredible competence and exuberance and genuine excitement and kindness because I was a guest on his theater people podcast back in 2016. And then friends of mine wanted to start a podcast with me. I guess I've been doing it for seven years since 2018. And this venture with Patrick is my third venture And my favorite to date
But I wanted to thank you for that question But it was like you guys were Your first impressions of each other Came from your work, from your artistry From your admiration of each other's work Has like an artist crush on one another Yes, truly But isn't it interesting that Rose and Blanche's first impression
Was the accurate one, so to speak Do you know what I mean? About who Barbara was to her quote? and something else. So Mark Cherry is a friend of the podcast. I heard his interview. Okay. So you heard what he said.
And he said the thing about Rue McClanahan is how good she was at playing all the different colors of a character. And she could play in quotes. She could play a quote dumb. And I see or just kind of flighty. And I see that color in her in this episode. She's just so good at all those different nuances. But the theme that you talk about, so that really affects. you, Jenna, the theme of this episode.
That's part of it. Yeah. What's interesting to me is that it made me reflect because, you know, at the end, Blanche and Rose's assessment of Barbara is correct that she's a crappy person. But it made me reflect about how in my relationship with Angela, we've each had different, like, friends that we've brought into our lives that we like. And every once in a while, there's someone that Angela and I are like, huh, really? Like, Angela will make a new friend and I'll be like, I don't care for her.
And the other way around. And then other times there's people where I'm like, oh, my gosh, she's a peach. I love her. What a gem of a person. And it's kind of interesting to me because after I watched this episode and I was thinking about it. And I said it to you, Angela, I was like, have you noticed that the ones that the other person didn't like, they didn't actually stick around. Yeah.
Oh, interesting. Like, but not like in such a confrontational way or anything, but just a kind of like, huh. Like you didn't say go to hell. No, and I didn't say you can't be friends with her. I just said, I don't love her. Yeah. Or vice versa. Or you might just have that moment where you're like, hmm, okay, okay.
And then there's no like, I told you so, there's none of that. It's just how it just plays out. We're getting into a deep area here. This excites me. Let me ask you this question to the groom. Because we all have that shiny object syndrome in friendship. Since like when you're little kids, too, you're like you have your really good rider dies. And then some popular kid likes you and you kind of dump the other kid for a minute. And it's not the best quality, but we all understand what that's like. You know how psychologists or psychiatrists or therapists will say we're often drawn to a romantic partner that is tapping into some unhealed wound from our past? There's an attraction there. Maybe because of, not always, but because there might be some unhealed trauma. Do you think the same is true with some of these friendships that don't work out, that the attraction is so strong because they are a reflection of something you need to grow or look at? Just hypothetically, I'm sure it's not always that way. I think maybe.
I also think sometimes whatever your childhood trauma is, you get drawn to it because it's familiar. And then you have to be reminded that you don't want that. Yeah. And then sometimes you get drawn into relationships that heal, you know, that give you the opposite, you know, like my friendship with Angela is a healing friendship. You know, it's just a friendship of unconditional love and trust and support and all those things. And it heals me every day. I just love it so much. But, you know, like you said, the shiny object is, oh my gosh, go back to my early dating life. I mean, how much. much like I would be attracted to, I don't want to say, but you know, just like, I do, not the right person because it was familiar, you know, but it wasn't the healthiest thing. Yeah. Do you all follow Dr. Romney? She's a doctor who, she does a lot of like work around like narcissism and childhood trauma and stuff. And one of the things that she had a guest on her podcast and she said,
what is the number one sign of an adult struggling or an adult who has survived childhood trauma? And he said, without skipping a beat, he said, it's trying to make difficult people like you. And I thought, like, that really resonated with me. Like, when I look at some of the friendships that I've had in my life that have not worked out or that have ended disastrously, it's because I look at the fact that, like, they were difficult and they didn't like me or whatever. And I, it made it my mission to make them like me. and then ultimately it falls apart.
But I was like, oh, my God, that's, yeah, that really spoke to me. Yeah. Are we a psychology podcast now? All of a sudden we might be. I mean, I do think to, and just to maybe wrap up this question, and something Jen and I have talked a lot about, is that there are seasons of friendship. And some people come into your life for that season.
That's who you were at the time. That's what you needed at the time. And then they might not grow with you, right? as you grow and that's okay and the other thing is though you do have people that are going to grow with you and that's the true true friendships and I'm so thankful for my friendship with Jenna and we didn't meet as young you know we weren't teenagers you know we don't have those high school memories we didn't know each other in college we met later in life and I think that's really special too because I think sometimes you think, well, I'm too old to make a really good friend or
you close yourself off to that kind of meaningful friendship. But you're not. You're not too old to make a really good friend. I love that. Did you all meet on the office? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. This is we literally met because we were the two closest women to each other. So we just had, we had a partition between us. and we would stand up. I would stand up over the partition and talk to you. Well, and Angela was also, to me, the physically closest person because the reception desk was kind of an island. But I could pass notes to Angela over the partition or between takes.
I could just stand up and we could talk. But for me to talk to anyone else, it was like a literal journey. She had to come out from around the, you know, that reception desk. I'm sure you've been asked us 10 million times and have answered. this 10 million times. But was the character's name, Angela? Or did they just like, they're like, we like that name? We'll just let you use your real name. You know, basically what Greg has said was there were some new characters that didn't have
names or weren't in the original BBC version of the show. And he just, in the writer's room, they were just kind of lazy and gave them our names. So it's Phyllis, Creed, Angela. Right, of course. Yeah, yeah. And it was just enough to confuse the hell out of everybody. So, great. Well, before we let you go, we have to talk about.
So Jen Samart is not the only stage star on this call right now because Ms. Jenna Fisher is doing a play very soon. Yeah, Ashland Avenue at the Goodman Theater. I love the Goodman. I'm so excited. My husband wrote the play. He went to school in Chicago. He went to theater school at DePaul. And this play is a real love letter to Chicago.
It's about a small business owner in Chicago who is kind of dealing with the fact that maybe the world doesn't want small businesses anymore in a way. Like they don't want his small business. And so he's trying to hold on to it. It's kind of a family dromedy. I play this character's daughter. But I'm so excited. I mean, I am a huge theater nerd. I texted my vocal coach today. And I read my script with my coffee. I just try to read it a couple times a week. We start rehearsals soon and then it opens in September. Oh, wonderful. And who's directing it? Susan Booth, the artistic director of the Goodman. And then Fran Geinen plays the lead. He's like a big Chicago legend. So I can't believe I get to play his daughter and it's a really
great cast. Is this your first time on stage professionally? No, this will be my third time. So I got my degree in theater. So it's my first love and it's kind of all I want to do now moving forward, you know, save for like if there's some cool little movie role or something that I can sink my teeth into. But my hope is that as my kids graduate from high school, I'll move to New York and just try to make it as a theater actress. Seriously, Jen, you're her goal in life. You're her goal in life. It's true. But I can't sing and dance. I can't sing and dance. So you're not going to see me in any musicals. That's okay. Let's do a play together. We did it out of time. We did it. We did out of town in Chicago, and it's the greatest theater town, and I'm sure you're going to be wonderful and break legs. And this is thrilling. And yes. And look, New York's not going anywhere. So come on. Come on. The water's fine. Come on in. Thank you. Oh, my gosh. Jen, it's all I want to do. I'm just so excited. Yay.
Steve and I are going to come and see it. No question. I can't wait. Stop it. Stop it. For sure. Okay. Well, you let me know when you come. I'm going. I'm going to go to the opening. If you're going to go, I would love to hang out with you. We could grab a drink. Oh my God. If that's it really. invitation, then that is what I'm going. Well, yeah, I'll, I'll picture. Yeah, give me your deets. I don't know what. What do we say?
What do the kids say today? I don't know. Do we say deets? Well, and Angela, you have a cookbook coming out. I do. You guys, my husband is amazing cook. He's a phenomenal baker and just an amazing chef. And he's self-taught.
And it's really just, I think, a gift that he had within him because I don't know how he's so good at everything, like from cookie decorating to takes to, you know, one pot dinners. The man is just a natural in the kitchen. But he really wanted to do a cookbook because something he has really helped me and the kids with is not being afraid to try to cook and get in there. And I was always like, I can't cook. I can't cook. And he'd be like, you can. And it's where we really fell in love was in our kitchen. I mean, just over a meal together. We met later in life. You know, we were divorced with kids. And that's the heart of our was the kitchen. And so we've been cooking together. We did some YouTube videos. And, you know,
we've been out there for a while, bacon with Josh and Ange, because my family calls me Ange, Jen, so you can call me Ange. You can call me Angie and Patrick. Bacon with Josh and Ann. That's the name of the cookbook? That's sort of our YouTube and our Instagram and all of that. But that is what led years and years of us cooking together and making all these recipes. And he, He has so many great recipes that he has tweaked and made his own. And the cookbook is called You Can Make This. Because that's what he always says to.
I love that. I'm going to do this. I'm going to learn to cook. That's like my big dream. You had me at one pot dinners. Yes. I don't have a lot of time. There's like a one sheet.
Okay. One pot. One sheet. Mm-hmm. Yeah. And soups. Oh, yeah. He loves a soup.
And it's just, it's really accessible, easy recipes that are really delicious. and the food photography, like, you know, we always just take pictures ourselves. And we hired this gal, Victoria Harris. The book is so beautiful. So I could not anticipate that. I'm like, oh, my God, this is so beautiful. And it's coming out in October. So October 22nd, guys.
But you can pre-order now. You can pre-order now. Oh, there it is. Pre-order now. We will. We will. We will. Oh, my God.
Thank you. Well, Angela and Jenna, we love you so much. This has been a dream since. before we even launched. So thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you for doing this. Thank you for having us. I don't want to leave. I don't want to leave.
I love you guys. Will you come back and do it again? Sure. Absolutely. Well, you know, who knows, Patrick? Maybe when we actually get to the Barbara Thundek episode, I have a feeling Jenna took notes and did her homework. Did you do homework?
I took notes too. She did. So maybe, so maybe, so season three. I reached out to your team and I was like, I don't want them to feel like they have to take notes. We can't help our selves. We couldn't help our own. Dorothy and Rose did their homework.
So maybe for the Barbara Doris, the actual episodes, it's not far from now. We could, is it season four? Season three. It's coming up soon. It's coming up. I think it's season three episode 50. Yeah. Yeah.
I have more thought. Get a little tea there. I'm coming to your show. You can't keep me away. I hope you are. And we're getting the book. And you're going to get an email today. Jen, I can't wait to see you on stage.
My gosh. Yes. Let me know. me know, and we'll say hi. You come up to the dressing room. Oh, my God, that would be amazing. All right. You guys, thank you so much.
What a wonderful morning. We love you, besties for the rest of you. Yay! Bye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.